let's see six one seven eight three zero
4750 is the number let's go to our
caller from the two one five area code
caller from two one five what's your
name where are you calling from
hello that is you hi David I'm by tally
from PA I actually call in five you
actually called in you were saying
I called in a while back yeah big fan of
your show I just wanted to get two
questions in there really quick my first
question would be what is your opinion
on getting rid of presidential term
limits because I know that was
established when FDR came into the oh
because of FDR's popularity I'm against
it I think we should keep presidential
term limits okay so my second question
would be and regarding - Andrew yang I'm
assuming you're gonna have him you know
interview him again you know we were
talking earlier this week how we've been
interviewing him before any of these
mainstream corporate media outlets did
and now he's kind of been dodging us I
hope that he hasn't gotten a big for us
but yeah we're trying to get him back on
for sure I mean yeah I don't know uh
definitely would love to see him on
because I know I've seen him on Rogan
and some other places but I think he was
on Fox News and you know his reaction
was pretty good but if you do have him
on I was hoping you could bring up a few
issues because even though I really love
them as a candidate he is my second
choice and next to Bernie and I do still
have some skepticism so I was wondering
if you could ask him about like his
stance on bank regulation specifically
if you could bring back like
glass-steagall why he doesn't fully why
is he not fully on board with free
tuition college Ryan you know see if he
could kind of push him to that direction
yeah the tuition free college question I
want to deal with him on because I know
that his position and mine differ the
bank regulation stuff I know less about
his position on that but I can certainly
look into it
yeah I tried looking and I couldn't
really find anything actually tweeted
Adam to see if he could clarify I know
like originally I was a little bit
skeptical on like what his position was
on the 70% marginal tax rate for the
wealthy but I've recently just had he
supported the green ideal yeah so I
think he's in the clear there and I
guess my last question would be in terms
of like yank versus Bernie aside for
electability reasons is there anything
that you would dislike is there any
specific reason you would support one
over the other no I mean I'll tell you
once I make that decision I just haven't
made that decision yet but yeah I mean
eventually I will be supporting one or
the other or Elizabeth Warren would be
my guess based on the candidates that
are running right now and I'll be
totally transparent about about why that
is when when we get to that point okay
well yeah that's all I have all right
thanks for the call really appreciate it
vitaliy from PA Pennsylvania I assume
that that means